pour ne louper aucune vidéo abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche salue les
épis curieux connaissez-vous le cac qui
ça ressemble à une tomate mais ça n'a
rien à voir on peut le déguster entre le
mois d'octobre et le mois de janvier
drôle de nom pour un fruit dans la
couleur ne tire jamais sur le kaki mais
plutôt sur le rouge orangé bizarre mais
ce n'est rien à côté du nom de l'arbre
sur lequel il pousse un plaqueminier du
japon et ce n'est pas fini
et cette essence a été domestiqué
notamment au japon et en chine et son
nom lui vient d'amérique de la côte est
d'une région correspondant grosso modo à
la floride où poussent une variété
locale
les indiens algonquin qui vivait l'ont
baptisé qui acquit mina qui devint
plaqueminier lorsque l'arbre fut un
produit en europe à la fin du xviiie
siècle
aujourd'hui en france il pousse
essentiellement dans le sud du pays
mais on en trouve également dans la
vallée de la loire goûtez y
c'est délicieux entre la mangue et la
pêche
cbre d'ailleurs son nom scientifique qui
vient du grec
il a très bien bio spyros le fruit des
dieux c'est vrai qu'on pourrait en faire
un caprice mais bon on va pas en faire
un fromage
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à laisser un pouce bleus merci les
épis curieux pour les plus gourmands en
voici d'autres et pour ne rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche
[Musique]